you talk a lot about the Jets so you and
your brother apparently haven't missed a
game one of my colleagues in the room
earlier asked me said you know what if
Mr Marriott asked Gary to come to a
meeting but it was joined at Jets game
never you think he'd come you wouldn't
come on for Mr Marriott not only for Mr
Marriott Miss Mary it's not even in the
[__] ball game I've missed weddings
funerals birthdays I do not miss jet
games I am think about the most
religious person you've ever known
whatever their religion is and whatever
they need to do whatever that is that
person's not even in the universe to my
religion of the Jets I have not missed
watching a play of a New York Jets game
since 1982. I've watched them all so how
are you looking for that acquisition
purchase deal how long is it going to
take I've been waiting a while my friend
my my great professional ambition is the
thrill of the chase to try to buy them
if I can just get it done before I die
I'd be very happy